when it comes to eSports history
underdog run and unlikely upsets have
made for some of the most compelling and
unforgettable stories dota 2 has
contributed more than its fair share of
these iconic
however you are more extraordinary than
when a humble Filipino squat bravely
stood up to a European giant harnessing
the magic of the International to pull
off what can only be described as a
miracle you're heading into the
International 2016 og were clear
favorites to claim the aegis of the
immortal guys with a bracket yeah
the tune was composed of incredible
talent and a wealth of experience which
translated into five titles at
significant events including two major
wins in Frankfurt and Manoj on the
opposite end of the spectrum TNC came
into ti6 with no such man fair TNC had
never even made it past the Southeast
Asian qualifier for any of the majors
however after bringing in American
veteran Jimmy demon Howe they finally
qualified for ti6
fueled by the passion of their fans and
their own love of the game they carried
the hopes of a nation with them to the
biggest stage and all of these words
with the weight of expectation on their
shoulders Oh G came charging in to
Seattle thank you no survive is the
finger because it's not the ogre we'll
bring him down to a narrow zone gaze
Bulldog be horse back the European
juggernaut conquered group a sweeping
aside TNC in the process who appeared to
be a minor footnote on og seemingly
faded pass to the ages despite mixed
results in the group stage a bit of good
portions thought ENC finished fifth
managing to qualify for the events lower
bracket there they easily dealt with
their first-round opponent vici gaming
reborn
it's about noise as the Filipinos
punched their ticket into the next round
the unthinkable happens
oh geez stumble losing two-to-one to the
Korean squad and the companion the
clear-cut tournament favorites now found
themselves in the lower bracket with og
having shown their mortality and tnc
riding the momentum of an impressive win
the stage was set for the rematch it
going to be careful wait I can't just
assume that this is a straight forward
wing TNC showed no fear in game 1
drafting the aggressive skirmishing trio
of AX lifestealer and vengeful spirit
while their other selections gave them
flexibility and late-game
Oh G opted for a greedier draft with a
three carry core in drow Ranger Medusa
and faceless void while the game didn't
unfold exactly as planned for TNC
they're more skirmish heavy lineup so
it's all the early fights even though oh
jeez cores led in network and experience
it didn't matter in the face of chancy's
brilliant coordination and keen plating
problem he does a rip off the Cougars
still keep battling he brought down why
her gear in trouble come to console
finger away from this bumper the hack
but bling double cold pick on extra help
this one packs they wonder how they well
that originally seems like every time Oh
G tried something TNC was one step ahead
playing patiently and reacting perfectly
to punish oh jeez errors so with this
max in course he'll break the smoke a
big composition and he capped at the
third foul apply the backline thirds how
are my boys named America eternal ages
baby with a current fear has balls the
surrogates
police loved it there's enough glitter
on the back line and lifestealer
that done the work you can see not even
miracle stead Medusa to hold back to
tied at EMC
as Cooter's diffusal blade phantom
Lancer rip Dream Team transit fake the
bottom rack will drop you'll get wanting
to kill them illusion evening this
should be the game right now be insane a
methodical metric called killing of hard
day
I think the indeed we're just a better
team here which is a huge surprise for
me because I thought this was going to
be OD a team that was heading into game
to the team's roles were reversed
Oh G selected a much more mid game focus
roster with ogre Magi ember spirit and
the deadly combo of IO and painting
while T and C went for the trio of drow
ranger faceless void and their signature
the high-risk husk are backed up by
daven within 10 minutes
Oh G had jumped out to an early lead
taking off individual members of TNC and
aggressively pushing towers to assert
control over the map aerosol evening
Minerva and the train line sounds
available they just off the bra out of
the p1 power the dark view while
returning you the damage I'm not to find
the kill in that crew live prank like
right partner to 10 t3 on the backline
this don't get PSD a change occurs with
Nutella crepe until standard ground down
be brought down t and c 5s really to
gain a foothold in the match engaging in
teamfights and taking roshan but despite
their best efforts OG continued to edge
them out at every turn
only widening the gold deficit couple of
one shot work commit them and now Kerkar
attempt he had the left part of it via a
guard when they're all outside of it
they can move orbital it's burned but
then he says any won't suffice as once
miracles or triple kill as the match
progressed TNT adapted to OGIS
aggressive tactics leading them to
secure a few crucial momentum building
till now miracle up north
keep turning
with a beard damage despite a fist demon
demon sir Lawrence a Saturday when they
bring down miracle and I'll break down
fruit as well
the tenth forward Creek does have real
ER came to three dances miracle 1/4 they
probably get Lewis grades are the cream
has a 1 charge of craving boiling and
because the find the kill there are two
of them now go get the analyser son is
dead inside a bit it is gonna be enough
damage to get through the faceless void
for the look quiet
wow what team fight come here 15 see the
display finding themselves 15 thousand
gold ahead at the 40-minute mark og was
still unable to land a finishing blow
against their resilient Filipino rival
Sun is getting waiting it's high Matt
Berger will battle against Prince the
team's will keep him alive also give me
the regeneration of nur tell who's
hunting the back ones keeping the dirt
range or off the cookers he puts their
towel drop the miracle of alive once
again and maybe peasley don't want to
buy something from nerds house he gets
away he steals gusted up they'll get
back to the history Tala miracle looking
to make the space moon again with
another jump in but aperture is the US
cos they've got a beer it's not to
mention be array versus that damage with
a gust pushing miracle away two phases
boil 30 life if I walk off the damage
rate in the trees note I will finally
can I kill ultimate E&Z member perryk
omega swine what TMC's persistence began
to pay off SMA is produced a series of
game-changing chronosphere yourself boyd
moves our Buckhorn I want the crit there
really is committing for one kill all
the others they don't care as long as
they get the kill that old fart is all a
miracle called out again good timing on
the Gulf miracle el imposition ease down
and I'll break free tiny well did you
tell a great reporters
outer-box hit by that builder and eli
protectin vkb will come out
he needs will help however an attorney
in Des Moines being at the three P's
protocol in small towns are itself the
goal are able to attract me to him and
there's no so far away from the fight
the tiniest down with no fight back
nearing the hour mark but with momentum
now on their side TNC forced out oh geez
buybacks and went for the gg push what
happened next
no one will ever forget do they go for a
GG push yes they are they're attacking
the people right they're gone it's dead
do you see Donna see applause whoa
in one of the most monumental instances
in DotA's history the Filipinos took
down the two-time major winners to
advance in the bracket eliminating the
tournament favorite and emerging as the
most unlikely of heroes
you're the results shot the dota World
and rewarded the faith of the passionate
community back home in the Philippines
although TNC would exit the tournament
in the following round
that's hardly remembered what does hold
up against time however is the story of
determination and skill which led TMT to
overcome the most ridiculous pogs
these days TMT are a household name in
the world of dota having won $800,000 at
W ESG 2016 cementing their claim and the
legitimate threat in the SCA region as
for oh geez the devastating loss call
for a roster shake-up but success would
soon return as fly and no tail would
lead their revamp roster to convincingly
win the Boston major a few months later
perhaps someday these two teams will
meet again at the International or even
the upcoming major in Kiev and more
history will be made but until then we
celebrate the day TNC stood a hundred
feet tall and the Philippines ruled the
world say I'm not that a truly iconic
eSports moment
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button